Chicago O'Hare Airport is shutting down
and moving their whole hotel shuttle
pickup area so it can house illegals
they're also restricting media access
and threaten that media cannot enter the
facility O'Hare has been using the
shuttle area to house illegals for
months and now there are too many why
are they trying to hide this there's a
sign at Chicago oare that reads hotel
and off airport shuttle starting
February 1st all hotel and off Airport
parking shuttles pick up in the lower
level arrival Lanes of Terminal 2 the
pickup sites is a short walk from
baggage you then have this uh ordd bus
shuttle Center media policy of course
saying you know contact media relations
but there have been illegal immigrants
on mattresses on the floor in O'Hare
Airport and it's not just the airport
there is huge concerns in Chicago
because they had plans to build camps is
funny because that you know whoopy
Goldberg says Donald Trump's going to
put people in camps what do you think
they're already doing in Democrat Run
Chicago now this plan to build a camp
was postponed and delayed so what are
they doing sending them to schools yeah
look if you want to make an argument
about how we handle legal immigration I
am all for legal immigration but it has
to be done legally and there has to be a
process by which we determine how many
people can actually come into this
country maybe as Laura says the answer
is for now it's not any and maybe the
answer is it's very few or maybe
actually if it's done legally there is a
a an appropriate number for the time
being what we're seeing is the the the
economy in these in these cities is is
at serious risk you can't have camps
being propped up you have kids Young
Young Americans who can't afford to pay
their rent can't afford their groceries
but then we're finding out that some of
these migrants are getting in I think
it's in Chicago $7,000 a month in public
benefits one illegal immigrant who is
brought here the B Administration
facilitates this with human traffickers
and Smugglers puts them on
Transportation brings them to these
places around the country he's been
doing it for for years now and then the
taxpayer funds to the tune of $84,000 a
year per person and young people aren't
even making that much money what would a
moratorium look like uh immigration Mor
because we got people that live here
that are like getting their Green Card
they've been in the process for three
years they're waiting and like in 9
months they're going to finally become
get their citizenship I guess I I mean
I'm not in office so I guess that it
would have to be whoever well let's just
say president Trump gets back into
office it would perhaps there would be
some type of system in place to you know
keep the people who had already legally
begun their process who are in the
process and then it just begins so it's
not it's not necessarily retroactive of
course if you're illegally we would have
mass deportations but I think going
forward there definitely needs to be a
halt right a halt on visas and I mean
it's a national security threat as well
not just an issue of replacement we saw
this recently with all of these uh
anti-israel and pro Hamas uh protests in
America I mean these people are openly
supporting terrorist organizations and
and they're they're shouting death to
America death to Jews death to
Christians and then you have illegal
aliens these are not just Mexicans and
Guatemalans right these are people
coming from the Middle East coming from
Africa okay and they're sleeping inside
our airports I mean what happens if you
have some lazy uh you know low IQ TSA
agent that falls asleep or isn't paying
attention or is texting and one of these
uh jihadists who comes across our border
illegally or somehow gets shipped to uh
the airport uh by the Biden
Administration makes it into the airport
and sets off a bomb in one of the
largest uh airports in our country
that's my absolute bigest that's my
biggest fear honestly that's my biggest
fear is that one of these days one of
these illegals is going to set off a
bomb in you know Grand Central Station
or one of the airports that's my biggest
fear M mine is that groups of them are
going to actively be planning something
like we're we're at War right now this
country is at War and whether you want
to Congress didn't declare it I don't
care we're at War that's the truth of it
in the Ukraine in Israel we're backing
that bombed Yemen yesterday uh okay so
we're at War you close your borders when
you go to war you don't let because the
enemies will send their people in that
you they look like citizens and they go
to the cities and like nine of them will
be on a Facebook group like okay I'm
they're already here the the you saw the
memo I I released this I broke this
story several months ago and then Daily
Caller received the official memo and
published it I'm sure you could pull it
up but they've already confirmed just
weeks after October 7th that you have
active Hamas and Hezbollah Terror cells
in major American cities uh like Atlanta
like Chicago like Washington DC New York
City and we saw them we saw their po we
saw them taking photos of themselves in
uh Time Square holding the Hamas flag so
we already know that these people are
here they're just waiting I look at it I
look at it from a totally different
angle in that we've had the war on
terror we've had an increased powers for
the FBI the surveillance State
everything else and we've had open
borders for the past 20 plus years and
we still have had no real serious
domestic terrorism threats I mean very
very minimal so I think that it has
always been overstated that the rest of
the world is prepared to blow themselves
up to cause us harm if we were to
actually treat them with any level of
Civility and respect I don't think we
would have anything to fear and those
that we're coming across our borders we
could actually stream line it make it
legal and and focus on bringing in
people that intend to be productive as
opposed to those that are looking for
handouts these are very simple answers
to the problems that we face and yet we
continue to just like pretend as if
you're going to have Trump get in there
and and remedy all this it's like the
the powers that be have already
demonstrated that they will undermine
him every step of the way unless he's
going to come in there and that he was
asked a few days ago is he interested in
retribution and he said I'm I don't have
enough time for retribution if you don't
have time for Retribution you're not
going to fix anything you have to
prosecute fouchy you have to it's not an
option he damaged the entire planet with
his funding of that well yeah personally
I also just wanted to add that I that
I'm also uh more uh afraid of all the
illegals that the CIA brings in as of
course in 2001 there was even a state
department official whistleblower that
came out on the record and said hey uh
these uh these guys that were uh you
know the 911 hijackers they were denied
visas at first first until the CIA
intervened and got them into the United
States because of their deliberate
interference and them stopping
government agents from stopping the
actual bad guys from coming in so I I I
think they want the bad guys to come in
I think they want this kind of terrorism
as the FBI's warning people saying hey
you guys should watch out as we're
watching for Trump supporters and people
who go to parent teacher School
conferences I completely agree with you
and I think that they want it because
they want to blame Trump supporters
right like you just said they want to
make it seem like the biggest threat in
this country is the white Christian male
or you know the white Trump supporter
when in
reality the Deep State and all of these
federal law enforcement agencies they
benefit every single time there's a
terrorist attack like an actual
terrorist attack right because they get
to expand the surveillance State they
get to push for gun control and as we've
seen they have some of these uh jihadist
terrorists on their payroll look at the
case of Omar matine in Orlando Florida
the Pulse Nightclub shooter we found out
after the fact that he was not only
being monitored by the FBI but his
father was literally an FBI informant
and then he was given front row seats at
Hillary Clinton's rally when she was
campaigning for president wow so Luke's
100% spot on they are they are training
they are propping up these people it
doesn't even it doesn't them to attack
us it doesn't even have to be a real
terrorist attack they can just make it
seem as if there's one and they can
still roll out and increase the the
surveillance State and the funding for
the FBI which by the way if Trump once
again I'm sorry I got to Circle back to
this if Trump isn't in interested in
retribution he is once again going to be
undermined if if you're not interested
in retribution against the FBI which
attempted to coup you
like more they have to do hear I didn't
hear that clip but I do know that
there's multiple you know clips from
president Trump's rallies where he says
I am your retribution and I know for a
fact from my own conversations with
President Trump as well that he 100% you
know he says it publicly so it's not
like I'm saying anything private he says
I am your retribution so I would I would
push back on that a little bit because I
don't necessarily agree with you maybe
you know there was some context missing
or perhaps he was making a sarcastic
statement at the Town Hall he
specifically said we're not he said
we're not going to have time for
Retribution because we're going to make
this country so successful and don't
forget our retribution is our success
right I'm paraphrasing but that was the
gist of what he said I think I think
they're attempting to frame him as some
sort of fascist dictator so he's he's
trying to now reframe it as no I'm not
going to go in there looking for
Retribution look I it may be politics
all I'm saying is if he is to get that
second shot yeah I need him to actually
mean it and he's going to but I agree
with you I do think that maybe it's a
messaging I don't work for Trump you
know but maybe because the media went so
crazy when he made his little joke about
oh I'm going to be a dictator for one
day they're obsessed with it and now he
talks about it at every single campaign
rally perhaps perhaps they are messaging
like you just suggested so people don't
actually think he's going to go out and
be a dictator although I personally
wouldn't mind dictator Trump I mean if
it
means it
means if it means retribution right if
it means shutting down the FBI closing
our border if that's what dictator Trump
looks like then bring it on right but
I'm pretty sure Donald Trump isn't just
going to get back into office and you
know say oh it's business as usual with
these people that decided to completely
screw my family and screw me and jail my
supporters as political prisoners for
the last three years the man's facing
700 plus years of prison potentially if
he's if he's not upset about that to the
point that he actually like you don't
have to do anything di dictatorial you
have to enforce the laws you're
surrounded by criminals get an AG that
will prosecute these scumbag he's going
to I think it's just the media the media
is just so you know they weaponize it
and then you even have conservatives
like Nikki Haley who say oh well Trump's
going to be a dictator right while she's
actually you know using the police to
kick journalists like myself out of her
event so Donald Trump has the GOP
establishment against him he has the
Democrats against him he has the media
against him and you know it'd be great
if it's not that his campaign doesn't do
good messaging but look president Trump
has to spend spend hours every single
day sitting in a courtroom okay he has
to spend hours traveling right he just
had a he had a town hall in Iowa the
other night and then imagine how
exhausted he must be flying from Iowa in
a snowstorm to New York City sitting in
a courtroom with that corrupt judge
Arthur and Goron and letia James all day
and then flying back to wherever he flew
next and then he's coming to uh to Iowa
again it's just yeah I think he's doing
the best he can no he's going nonstop
just really quick the The Whistleblower
I mentioned was Michael springman at the
jeda consulate look into his story
because it really does reveal a lot of
the the government agents working within
uh the federal bureaucracy that that
want bad people to come in and do really
horrible things to the American people
so they did it before they were never
held accountable for it they're going to
probably do it again thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at
timcast.net we'll see you all next
time